if you don't own a wii-u or if you've
skipped out on Mario Kart 8 the first
time around Mario Kart 8 deluxe is
absolutely the version to get it plays
beautifully on switch in both handheld
and dock mode and its core racing is as
exciting as ever and most notably it
completely revamped the originals
lackluster battle mode rounding out a
great racing game in the original
version of Mario Kart 8 battle mode
disappointingly repurposed tracks
designed for regular racing instead of
having special arenas designed
specifically for chaos and popping
balloons all of those tracks have been
replaced in deluxe and the battle maps
we get make all the difference there are
five new maps and three retro Maps and
each has choke points great for face
offs built around central areas where
you can mercilessly toss items at your
friends and unlike on regular race
tracks those items have a much greater
chance of actually hitting someone
instead of flying off to the side
pointlessly the splatoon inspired urgent
underpass and the almost overwatch like
dragon palace are standouts in order to
fully take advantage of these new maps
battle mode introduces modes that
weren't in the original balloon battle
is of course back but with a few tweaks
you get five balloons to start instead
of three and it's point-based rather
than just last-man-standing there's a
completely new mode called renegade
roundup that's very similar to cops and
robbers tag meaning it capitalizes on
Mario Kart 8 strong racing for a
different kind of battle and finally
there are three modes from previous
Mario Kart games ba bomb blast coin
runners and shine thief that all
complement the maps with my personal
favorite being the explosive competitive
mayhem of Bob on blast you have to drive
around collecting item boxes throw the
bombs you get at your opponent and avoid
getting hit with bombs yourself and it's
very easy to get way too competitive all
those modes combined make this the
varied exciting battle mode that Mario
Kart 8 should have had all along
regular racing is as strong as in the
original and gets minimal updates in
this version all tracks and characters
from Wii U including the DLC have
returned and there were also a few new
characters to choose from but no new
tracks the ability to carry two items at
once is back from the double dash days
and that means slightly more items on
the track to keep you on your toes but
your driving ability still matters and
although it's nearly identical to Wii
U's Mario Kart 8 racing and deluxe is as
enjoyable and rewarding for skilled
players as it was originally deluxe also
adds some small quality of life updates
that make for a more polished package
load times are shorter on switch than on
Wii U and the game takes advantage of
the joy Khan's vibration capabilities
off-roading is bumpier and drifting
boosts feel more satisfying thanks to a
stronger sense of acceleration plus you
can change your cart configuration in
multiplayer without having to leave the
lobby first even if you didn't really
care about battle mode the smallest
changes in Mario Kart 8 deluxe refine an
already great racing game but the huge
overhaul to the originals afterthought
of a battle mode is a chaotic varied
opportunity to play very differently
than in Grand Prix mode and well worth
reinvesting yourself in Mario Kart 8 on
switch
[Music]